a marks world aids day nearly 40 million  people around the world live with hiv  680 thousand people died from aids  related illnesses last year  but there's hope scientists have a new  treatment for the disease for many a  daily cocktail of drugs keeps their  disease at bay but at queen mary  university in london professor chloe  orkin and her team have developed a way  to replace some of those pills with an  injection just six times a year  taking this to the to the next level and  reducing the treatment days from 365 to  six treatment days a year is a real  paradigm shift and a new breakthrough  the uk's national institute for health  found that her shot was just as  effective as taking all those pills  injection has also been cleared for use  in the united states